good morning believe nation today's
message is stay focused over to you but
Toria Beckham when I initially started
up the brand I didn't put too much
pressure on myself I didn't go into this
to prove anything to anybody other than
than myself I was very focused I didn't
try and do everything at once you know
her for quite a few seasons I stopped to
just perfecting the dress I didn't want
to run before I could walk it's very
important to be focused and do do what I
was doing very very well and move on and
do more when my team was in the position
to do that so I think that it's about
keeping things focused and not trying to
do too much I think this is one of the
things that sinks tons of entrepreneurs
so many entrepreneurs that I know are
the creative types where I creative
geniuses amazing and you have this idea
I think I love this ideas this is great
what an amazing idea and you're off
right now then and then poof you meet
somebody or some other idea comes to you
and then you forget this I'm gonna go
over here now and you start working on
this thing and poof you want to go this
way now you're off on some totally new
thing and you're sitting around with 25
different projects sitting at 50% done
and nothing ever gets the completion
that's so many entrepreneurs because you
can't focus on one thing at a time and
if you are that to the extreme like if
you can only be the idea generation
person and you just can never get
yourself focused then my advice to you
is and force yourself to be focused
because you're not gonna thrive but find
somebody to help finish these projects
get it to the point where you're making
some money with it and somebody can help
partner with you who is the super
operations detail-oriented focused
person to help get you through because
otherwise you're just going to be
sitting there on a pile of projects that
never get completed and you're never
gonna have the impact of success you
want as an entrepreneur
I'm porch enough to have both I can be
the creative and the visionary and go
and do big things and come up with new
ideas that haven't happened before
but I also like finishing stuff I like
having commitments I like scheduling
things in and keeping to my schedule
what I find the balance that I strike is
most days I wake up and I follow my
schedule things have to happen every
week and these are this is a schedule
that I follow Wednesday is my video
recording day I'm just coming to the
studio and I'm filming videos but then
on the days that come where there's some
crazy idea I'll go for it I'll start it
I'll work on it to the expense of
everything else in my schedule I'll move
meetings I'll switch video day around
because when I can get in that zone then
I can create some amazing stuff but
that's not every day I don't wake up
every day in the zone really working on
some new creative idea so I find that
that balance really works for me what
I've done is I always start a project
myself myself my energy my time my
hustle my drive and then as it builds up
I either get it to the point where I can
afford to bring on a team to help me
because it's making some money or I
don't and I drop it off more projects
and most people start when I started
this YouTube channel is a great example
I had a successful business I had a
website I still have a website I had a
team of people on my website I decided
I'm gonna start a YouTube channel I
could have taken money from that
business to start to channel to buy the
basics to buy the gear and all that
stuff I started with zero dollars doing
it just my time borrow gear borrowed
equipment I did the editing I did the
research I was in front of the camera I
did everything I kept my team doing what
they were doing building that business
while I went off and did this crazy
thing on YouTube now luckily it worked
and he built it up and now I built a
YouTube team around it but a lot of the
projects that I'll work on on my own
they don't take off you know in most of
it's because I don't I lose my
excitement for it like YouTube could
have been I made five videos he like you
know what that was a good try like I'm
glad I gave it a shot it's just I don't
enjoy it I'm gonna do it and I cut out
and so I think it's super important
you understand the personality type that
you are you have that self-awareness to
say either I can be more focused and I
need to I need to pick the project that
I'm gonna work on right this is
something I'm doing with with China and
salsa this business right here and Alex
I gave them ten options when we sat down
here the ten ways we can grow our
business ten different ways we can't do
all of them because we try do all of
them we're gonna suck at everything
and we have a whole bunch of 50%
projects this one we have to do you pick
one or the other nine he picked one and
every time you know it's tempting to
come back and say ooh whoo here's the
idea I saw this video that somebody put
out what if we did like this thing way
over here no focus forget that yes it
can work but it has to be done well
focus these two things that's what we're
doing that's it
don't worry about anything else and if
you don't have the discipline to put
that on yourself and it's not the skill
set that you want to build and develop
then you need to have somebody come on
and help you you need to have somebody
you could hand projects hop to and they
can run with it and you'd be taking far
enough to get to the point where you can
make some money with it and they can run
with it and help you build the business
while you move on to the next project in
the next five take your next project you
need to have that skill somewhere in
your arsenal either you develop it
yourself or you bring somebody on to
help you otherwise you're not gonna have
success as an entrepreneur so the
question today today is are you focused
enough at finishing the projects that
you start leave in the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to Steve
Saunders from Steve Saunders info Steve
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book your one word I really really
really really appreciate it thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events vessel
so as a special bonus for you guys I'm
adding some extra clips around staying
focused that I hope you'll enjoy and
we'll help how do you prepare yourself
with with to be so focused to handle of
all this massive stress really it's um
it's trying to just remain focused on
the job at hand and in the tasks my goal
this weekend is to win this race all the
other stuff is all just noise and it's
just I guess it's just through
experience kind of been out to silence
all that and stay focused on what's the
most important thing so they'll be
distracted by all the media all the
cameras you know I mean there's tomorrow
there's so many interviews mostly with
the same people that we always have so
I've been talking to these guys for 10
years but and they're often asking the
same question that they asked me the two
weeks ago but obviously they have
something more to talk about this
weekend because the last race was
terrible
but um I think it really is just trying
to I guess compartmentalize really that
that stuff put over here put in a box
and then you know keep the energy and
your focus on the one thing that matters
most all that other stuff does not
matter what matters is mean esteem how
we're gonna get from you know from
Friday or you know Thursday this week
for example to Sunday standing on top of
that podium and you know it's sleep it's
what I eat it's what I spend my time
doing making sure I get to bed early all
these different things that have to add
up to it and sometimes you do it all
perfect and it doesn't go well but
that's life and you just hope that in
doing all the right things but it's also
trying to find a balance you know you
need to enjoy life as well you know some
sage on the road
my career will be over and I want to
look back and say I did I enjoyed
absolutely everything every moment in
the car every every moment out of it
well when you're doing the TV show you
know every day is a different day in the
sense that it's never the same and you
might be shooting two scenes you might
have one scene you might have five
scenes so your level of preparation
is different every time generally I'm up
early I exercise I run I do whatever it
is I'm doing in terms of my physical
life other than playing tennis which I I
you know stack up during the course of a
week quite a lot of if I can and you
know get to set depending on your call
time but very often it's very early and
then you you know try to be there and be
alert and awake and alive and ready to
go every hour of the day and if you work
12 hours then you have to be alert every
one of those hours it's it's an
important thing to stay focused
it wasn't conscious on my part to to
have another scripts that are ready to
go by the time we went to you know film
festivals with following while we were
finishing up the cart on it and doing
very long slow technical finishing which
when you have no money takes forever
because you said waiting for the lab to
have a you know run the 60 ml bath you
know whatever it is in that time I was
putting together the script for memento
and so also in the time it took to get
following noticed on the first of all
circuit so get out there I had actually
finished the script and in retrospect it
was a massive advantage because I was
able to say okay you like that film this
is what I want to do next because in
your best-case scenario of what can
happen to you would with putting a film
out there and getting distribution for
example you're then asked the question
okay what do you want to do next and if
you have an answer you can use that very
short window of interest that you get
from people in what you've done but I
will say that I think that was purely an
accident and I think that if you were to
try and plan to you know write another
script while you were finishing a film
you really risk taking your focus off
the the project that you're doing and I
think that it's most important to just
throw yourself into just just putting
everything into the the project you're
working on and that's something I've
always done done since if you can
and because quite often there is a
period between finishing a project and
actually people seeing it or actually
people responding to it
if you can try and instead of going on
holiday for six months you use that
period to try and figure out what you
would do next if somebody gave you the
opportunity then then you're gonna give
yourself a huge advantage obstacles
really don't matter they really just
don't know more than will you come from
what you had what you have what you
didn't have all that stuff becomes so
what people that are concerned with
results and the person that's working
with their mind fixed on the end result
being success or a lot less concerned
about the problems in they're more
willing to explore solutions and if need
be create them that is probably the best
use of your energy - Watson Egger was
said to once give a seminar somewhere I
think they referenced it in the either
the the book the education of the
bodybuilder or the encyclopedia honest
watchmakers encyclopedia bodybuilding
one time giving a seminar it was said
that he talked about
focusing on his goal and how the only
time you can begin to really assess the
enormity of an obstacle was to have to
first take your eye off your goal that's
the end of my honest wit snake a quote
but I guess in recalling that at this
moment what I realize is you know if I'm
a NFL outside linebacker looking to try
to put a sack on the quarterback of the
opposing team if I am looking at the
size of the lineman in front of me
looking to stop me the defenders looking
to stop me from getting to the
quarterback if I start taking into
account how how big is his hands and how
much does this guy weigh in man look at
the size of his neck chances are in
order to make all of those assessments I
can't be looking at the quarterback
behind him anymore
and if my responsibility in this play
was to put pressure on the quarterback
and even better put my hands on the
quarterback from caused a fumble to stop
the play then I'm going to be rendered
ineffective not by anything the lineman
has done but because I have now taken my
eye off of the goal in order to assess
the size and weight of the obstacle in
front of me successful people I imagine
have to worry less about what the size
of the obstacles are the finances are
the lack thereof and all the other
things that we can say
represent the the size and weight of the
opposition and what the successful
person is going to aim to do and what
all of us would like to be successful
would probably want to adopt as a part
of our philosophy would be to worry less
about the obstacles and fix our thoughts
on the the goal